you're right there are some other
options for our 2D friend to have a
digestive system one option is a
self-gripping intestine like this the
upper half grips onto the lower half
holding the body together as food moves
through one gate opens at a time and
then closes before the next one opens
that way the body can't float apart on
an episode of Futurama 2D creatures were
like amoebas that fully absorbed food
before breaking it down and extruding it
you guys had some other interesting
ideas such as diffusing the waste in a
similar way to sweating that might work
as long as the sweat glands are isolated
from the rest of the digestive system
maybe a small transporter breaks off to
carry material to the edge if the sweat
glands were all connected our friend
would split apart into a thousand pieces
and we don't want that